don't identify with what your mind says
any more than you identify with what
someone on the street says how many
times have you thought a thing that
didn't turn out to be true you are your
most untrustworthy friend imagine all of
the things that you've thought that
didn't turn out to be true all of the
concerns that you had all of the fears
and the overthinking and the absolute
certainties about whatever catastrophe
was going to occur or absolute
certainties about whatever success was
going to occur and it didn't if you were
friends with that person you would think
that they were the biggest garbage on
planet
hello everyone welcome back it is the
400th episode the big 400
and to celebrate i thought that i would
give you some of my favorite lessons
from the last nearly four years of doing
the show four years sounds like a lot
it is
quite a lot i definitely didn't think
when we did the first episode in my
office
with a friend who was going to row the
atlantic naked
that we would have done 400 episodes
only
three and a half years later worked out
that there's been
five million hours
of modern wisdom content watched and
listened to
over the last three and a half years
which is pretty crazy uh so thank you to
everyone who tunes in who listens who
shares the episodes with friends who
messages me and sends nice things to
video guy dean or
supports the show in whatever way you do
it's very
very
appreciated there is nothing that i
would rather do at 6 p.m most weekday
evenings than speak to
whoever the hell it is a porn star or a
psychologist or a philosopher or a
sports person or me on my own
how it's going to be this evening and
i'm going to go through like i said some
of the best lessons that i've taken away
from the episode some of them are from
guests stuff that we brought up on the
show and others are part of during my
research for people that we're coming on
and then some are common themes that
i've noticed throughout all of the
episodes so let's get into it
number one you cannot overestimate the
unimportance of practically everything
this is a quote from john maxwell but it
reminds me of greg mcewen's work with
essentialism essentialism basically
reminds us that almost everything that
we spend our times doing uh they're
trivial nothings they don't contribute
to our higher order goals they don't
actually push us towards achieving the
thing that we genuinely want to and in
the modern world we have far more
opportunities to do things than time to
do them and far more things to do
than things that we care about which
means that we constantly get distracted
we get we stray from the path of the
thing that we're here to do the thing
that is genuinely our highest point of
contribution that we genuinely care
about we just get
fritted away distracted by shiny objects
and you can fragment your life into so
many tiny little slivers that you never
actually get any meaningful work done
you never progress toward the thing that
you genuinely care about
i'm pretty certain in fact i'm 100
certain that the biggest productivity
strategy in the modern world is just
getting ruthlessly clear about what it
is that you want to do and then culling
everything that doesn't contribute to it
what is the goal that you want to
achieve
and then what are all of the things that
don't contribute to that that you don't
have to do
just stop doing those like what's the
prize that you win for being the person
that keeps your instagram notifications
at zero all the time or what's the prize
that you win for being the fastest
person to reply in a group chat does
that move you toward the thing that you
genuinely want in life
probably not so why are you doing it you
cannot overestimate the unimportance of
practically everything it also reminds
us to stop overthinking we believe that
so many of the things that we decide
we're going to obsess over are really
really crucial to what it is that we've
got going on and they probably don't
matter and in a week's time you're
probably not going to remember the thing
that you were frantically concerned
about right now so
i really like that i really like the
idea of
trying to remember that no matter what
happens you're probably going to be fine
i mean you're
sat or stood here now listening to this
so you haven't met your demise just yet
have faith that you're probably going to
be okay in the future too
all right next one uh perfectionism is
procrastination masquerading as quality
control so this is
this is me quoting me
but thiago forte on the show probably
nearly three years ago now uh he
tweeted something that got me thinking
about this a paradoxical thing about
people who consistently choose the most
high leverage activity is their efforts
have a rough edged half-assed quality
because polishing things to perfection
is a low leverage activity
polishing things to perfection is a low
leverage activity what tiago is for
talking about here is
when you're trying to get better at
something and iterate on your craft
whether that be content creation or
writing or playing music or releasing a
new business or starting a new
relationship or whatever it is
people will use procrastination use
perfectionism as a form of
procrastination that they don't want to
begin doing something until they're
absolutely perfect on the brand name or
the logo or the timing or whatever
and it's stopping you from learning by
doing if you get something out into the
world you will learn by iterating and
reflecting on the process okay i did a
thing how did it go was it good was it
bad did i find it effective how can i
improve the next time that is
so much more worthwhile you're going to
benefit so much more from that than you
are from getting it from 90 to 93
quality and
it's a low leverage activity because
so many people get caught up trying to
go from 90 to 93 in that time you could
have done two 90s or 390s you could have
continued to release these bits of work
and someone replied to that tweet and
said perfectionism is a nice way to hide
from shipping at a pace necessary to
find what works so that's talking about
this iteration process you need to work
out how to be good at the thing that
you're trying to do and you don't learn
that by trying to be perfect you learn
that by being good enough and delivering
something to the market or to an
audience or to whoever it is
that you're trying to reach
that's how you do it you do it by
actually getting out there and shipping
your work
next up
you do not serve people from your cup
you serve them from the saucer which
overflows around your cup so this was
the first episode that i did with aubry
marcus and he blew my mind on that i
knew he had this big podcast and a
successful book and stuff and i'd listen
to him and i thought yeah he's he's good
but i i wasn't really sure on just
what it was going to be like in real
person and uh
yeah he really really impressed me the
guy's the real deal he's a very very
aligned awakened human and um you do not
serve people from your cup you serve
them from the saucer which overflows
around your cup this is jordan peterson
again right clean your room sort
yourself out before you go out and you
try to fix the world but what i like
about it is that it makes us it reminds
us that by
contributing to our own sense of
well-being by doing something meaningful
that we care about that we know is going
to make us a better person that everyone
else comes along for the ride if you
work very very hard on yourself you're
probably going to improve the lives of
the people that are around you
there was a uh
a concept that i thought about when we
were discussing that that just made me
think
how many people have tried to
pull from a half full cup how many
people are trying to fix the people that
are around them when they've got these
gaping holes in their own
mindset in their own
world view in their own daily routine
the same as being in a an airplane right
the masks come down you have to put your
mask on first before you help someone
else because if you're suffocating
you're of little use to everyone now
that being said
this isn't an argument for
ruthless selfish
single-minded capitalism just for you
doesn't mean that you have to wait to be
perfect before you can try and help
other people but that the best way to
serve others is to make sure that you're
sorted first i think that's the main
lesson to take away
next up do people love you for who you
are or for what you do so this is james
smith
uh asked himself this question when he
was off his face on mushrooms in bondi
beach somewhere listening to hans dimmer
and it's a really really good question
do people love you for who you are or
for what you do and
it's difficult to answer because
we are what we do right like when you
meet someone you say hi what's your name
what do you do so tell me tell me about
you what do you do
what you do
is almost more important it's seen as
more important than who you are in the
modern world it is your identity
and
do people love you for who you are or
for what you do
is a question that
forces us to work out
am i
am i being loved for what value i add to
the world or intrinsically for the sort
of person that i am
when i spoke to aubrey about this and
asked him this question he turned around
and said do you love you for who you are
or for what you do because what we're
asking the world to do is love us for
who we are right not for what we do
meanwhile we choose to love ourselves
for what we do not for who we are the
last business interaction that we had
the last sports game that we played the
last date that we went on the last
interaction with our kid or partner or
boss or whatever
that is what determines our sense of
self-worth for the next time up until
the next opportunity that we get to
reset that that's obviously that's
obviously wrong we're judging ourselves
on what we do not who we are we feel
like our self-worth is contingent on
the work that we put out into the world
we're asking the world to do something
that we haven't done yet so yeah do
people love you for who you are or for
what you do it's just an awesome
question and it really reminds us to
sort of focus on the the things that
matter most which is you sorting
yourself
first next up douglas murray
when the barbarians are at the door
we'll be debating about what gender they
are so
i heard him say this at a live spectator
event and
his
point is that there are genuine evil
people out there and that the west has
become
quite decadent and quite caught up in
its
uh
social justice identity politics world
and if china comes a knocking or if
there is a large global war the fact
that we have been caught up in the
culture for a long time debating
more trivial matters than
war and genuine evil uh we're not going
to look very good we're not going to i
don't think that anybody could look at
the west at the moment
and say that it's a strong powerful
good role model that it's cohesive
that people
feel like they're pulling together
none of these things
strike very true for me um but that
aside like when the barbarians are at
the door we'll be debating about what
gender they are is quite a funny quote
from douglas but what
i
tried to pull him up on the last time
that we spoke was
i don't like the idea that smart minds
are getting distracted by identity
politics so
douglas can say all he wants that
we shouldn't be focused on these sorts
of issues but
he gets brought he gets pulled into
these sorts of discussions and so do
andrew doyle and zooby and you know pick
your
center or right leaning commentator that
gets stuck into identity politics stuff
those guys get tied up talking about it
uh now whether or not they feel
justified whether they feel like this is
a real problem that we need to stop from
occurring or else they're going to
capture the culture and that's going to
have real issues
both sides are playing badly so one side
is baiting and the other side is
responding i appreciate that it's kind
of like oh well he did it first i'm not
going i'm not going to let them win so i
understand why it's there and don't get
me wrong i you know i see a libs of tick
tock video and i think this is
ridiculous i should do a reaction video
to that
but
if we are genuinely concerned about the
rise of china and russia and
misinformation and what's going to
happen with i mean we've just had a
pandemic that might have come out of a
lab
is this not is this not the time for us
to try and focus on things that matter
more um so yeah i feel like something
needs to change in the culture on the
right as well as on the left so on the
left they need to stop focusing on
mental work identity politics stuff but
on the right they need to
stop
treating them treating these news
stories with quite as much respect and
clout because it does
uh amplify the message of whatever
craziness it is now even if you're
mocking it that's fine but
i think there's been enough mocking of
crazy stories from the left
to have split tested the
can we mock this out of existence
uh drug it's not working it
taking the piss out of inherently
ridiculous and self-contradictory
identity politics videos
isn't stopping them from happening so
there needs to be another approach
i i genuinely think that ignorance isn't
too bad of an idea um
and at the very least the greatest minds
of our time shouldn't have their time
spent debating about whether men and men
and women and women are not that there
has to be something better that they
should spend their time doing and
douglas murray's had a pretty
long and illustrious reading writing
and academic career as far as i'm aware
i think andrew doyle went to some pretty
prestigious universities and zubi also
went to oxford and these people are
spending their time arguing on twitter i
want them to be doing better things and
i also want people on the left to be
doing better things because if you're a
moderate leftist
and the most
well
promoted
uh individuals from your side of the
aisle are these
purple head libs of tick-tock people
that that sucks as well like nobody
should be supporting what these people
are doing
but
yeah it's sort of like um you should be
bigger than it is maybe the question
i've got douglas coming on he's got a
new book coming out in
next year sometime april i think uh so
he'll be back on so i'll ask him about
this again
next up don't try to beat the market
just dollar cost average into it and
this is morgan housel's
investment advice so
there's this story that warren buffett
had a bet with a hedge fund manager and
he said you can pick i think it was with
another person that could pick five
different hedge funds and say you can
pick all of these you can pick whichever
hedge funds you want see what their
returns are over i think about seven
years and i'm gonna pick the s p and
whoever gains the most between the s p
and any of these five hedge funds
they win
the s p 500 one which is the um 500
biggest companies in the world an
aggregate of all of their
changes in value and
morgan is a guy who spends a lot of time
talking about finance and personal
investing
he's got a book called the psychology of
money which is an awesome awesome
read that you should go and check out
it's part of the modern wisdom reading
list which you should go and get
chriswilex.com
books for a free list of 100 books that
you should read before you die
and
yeah morgan says that most people try
and beat the market when all that you
need to do is track the market so dollar
cost averaging is
setting up an isa or any sort of normal
stocks and shares savings account and
just depositing a steady amount of money
into it every single month so yeah sure
there's going to be movements up and
down within the market but over time
you're going to catch most of them at
relatively all right points yeah maybe
you'll catch one when it's a little bit
high and then it pulls back and yeah
maybe you'll catch some when it's a
little bit low and it pushes up
over time it'll average out dollar cost
averaging and it just removes
most of the complexity i don't think i
certainly know that i don't have the
mentality or the mindset to be a trader
i've tried it i've tried picking stocks
and [ __ ] about an etoro
a man it is
for anyone that is a trader that's
listening you are a
psychopath inside because i don't
understand how you can
put up with watching
your net worth get ragged around at the
mercy of the market i'm just totally
totally not built for it
so rather than that the solution that
i've gone for which is what morgan
proposes
is to not try and beat the market to
just dollar cost average in so just put
money into a stocks and shares isa which
is linked 100 to the s p 500 i just do
that every month
that's it just every month same amount
goes in
you'd have to think about it you know
that it's
barring some sort of catastrophe and i
mean if the s p 500
crashes there are far bigger problems
than what's happened to your money we're
probably in the middle of some mad max
post-apocalyptic nightmare world
uh so yes that is probably the only
investing advice that
80 percent of people probably need to
know
next up
consistency is even rarer than talent or
enthusiasm so this was
just a common theme that i found
throughout a lot of the episodes where i
was speaking to people again
partly for business and content creators
but also just for people that want to
improve themselves or get good at
anything
lots of people find that they pick up a
new sport or a new pursuit and they have
a talent for it they have a natural
knack for whatever it is that they're
doing and other people also when they
start something new find that they're
enthusiastic about it it's quite common
you know it's basically
every january 1st in the gym you rock up
and everyone's keen to do something
they've got these new new year's
resolutions they're all enthusiastic and
some of those people will be talented
but how many of those people end up
being consistent long term how many of
those people do that thing
over and over and over again every few
days or every every week for years and
years and years almost no one because
it's not sexy it's not sexy and it's
boring and you will lose talent your
talent will only get you so far very
quickly after you do anything you're
going to be out of the pool of noobs and
into the pool of other people who are as
talented or maybe more talented than you
are who are as enthusiastic or maybe
more enthusiastic than you are and
that's why consistency is the perfect
competitive advantage because it's the
best way to do what we were talking
about earlier on which is to
leverage uh shipping at a pace that
allows you to know what works you get to
do a thing consistently the market or
your audience gives you feedback you go
okay well i'm gonna get better at that
this has gone well this has gone badly
we'll change it
and
it's so rare
that it's immediately going to separate
you out from almost all of your
competition so
this statistic about podcasts that 90
don't make it past episode 3 and of the
10 that do 90 don't make it past episode
20 so by making 21 podcasts you're in
the top 1 of all podcasters
ever and that's purely based on
consistency can you create 21 podcasts
okay there you go top percentile
podcaster
why what's because consistency is
[ __ ] well rare that's why
loneliness is a kind of tax you have to
pay to atone for a certain complexity of
mind this is a lander bottom from the
school of life now alan uh won't reply
to my emails or his assistant won't
reply to my emails so
this is what you would have said
um had i have going on the show this is
what he will say
when i eventually get a hold of him and
his little jumper sit him down in a seat
and speak to him loneliness is a kind of
tax you have to pay to atone for a
certain complexity of mind so the more
unique you are
the fewer people are going to be like
you and the fewer people will
get you
and this means that it can suck right
you can end up feeling a bit more
lonely because
it's harder to find people that you want
to have a conversation with if your
interests are perfect but a slap bang in
the middle of the normal distribution of
normal
then
everyone or the vast majority of people
are going to agree to the match last
night or [ __ ] what happened on
hollyoaks or whatever you can tell i'm
really [ __ ] with pop culture
um then there's going to be lots of
people for you to find to speak to
the difference is that if you have as
you start to push out toward those ends
of that distribution
there are fewer and fewer people who
genuinely are like you and it can cause
us to be tempted to compromise who we
are right we want to try and push
ourselves right into the middle
because we think well
even if i'm not fully embracing me
at least there will be other people like
me
so you'd rather be
a persona in a crowd than yourself on
your own
and i get this compulsion i i genuinely
do understand
but i think that the increase in depth
of insight is worth the entry price that
you pay
so
you get to see the world in a different
way to other people because you have
this unique perspective you have
different interests if you have a
slightly more complex mind then
yeah you're going to feel things more
deeply it's both a blessing and a curse
to feel everything so very deeply you
are going to
but also it means that you get to see
the world in a different way to other
people you will have a deeper insight
you will feel things in a
more nuanced and subtle and high
fidelity way which is pretty cool i
don't think that that's something that
you should let go certainly
not simply because you're struggling to
find someone to connect with
so
and the other thing as well is that over
time i mean this is the topic of my ted
talk basically
um tedx talk and not ted
didn't call
um
yeah that weirdness and compromising
yourself causes you to degrade your own
virtue
it's not what people actually want in
any case people think that they want to
be just like everyone else so people
think that people want people that are
just like everyone else but they don't
they want people that are
romantically unique and trailblazers
that have odd idiosyncrasies and quirks
that they can fall in love with that's
the people think about whoever it is
that you admire in the world you don't
admire them because they're
mind-numbingly normal because you know
one of their views and you can
accurately predict everything else that
they believe because what stops you from
loving somebody else that's the exact
same as them
the more unique that you are the fewer
people are like you and that's a big
thing to be proud of
imposter syndrome is a feature not a bug
of growing as a person so this was seth
godin uh marketing hyper genius
uh on the show
start this year maybe
end of last year and asked him about
imposter syndrome and he said that
why would you not feel impostor syndrome
when you're doing something brand new
that you've never done before especially
if it's maybe something that no one has
ever done before so we try and rid
ourselves of imposter syndrome or ask
why it's there but what imposter
syndrome is is uh an uncertainty in
yourself
around whether or not you can complete a
particular task or achieve a goal or
project or whatever that you've got in
front of you
but
if you've never done it before
then quite rightly you've got imposter
syndrome it's an accurate representation
of your uncertainty about whether or not
you're going to be able to do the thing
that you say that you're trying to do
so imposter syndrome isn't
a bug it's a feature
it's an accurate representation from
your mind thinking this is i'm
trailblazing some new ground here i've
never tried to lift this weight before
i've never tried to go out on a date
with this type of person before whatever
it is
like that's you just expanding your
domain of competence and if you think of
it like
if you feel a little bit of imposter
syndrome if you feel a little bit of
concern about whether or not you can
complete the thing that's in front of
you
what if you reframe that as a signal
that you are doing work which is good
which is growing you as a person
if it means that you're in the proximal
zone of development just just outside of
your competence
what if you saw it as that what if you
saw it as a
a
a line in the sand that you've crossed
that lets you know that you're trying to
do new things and on the other side of
this you should have proof that wow look
at my capabilities look at what i was
able to do
that's new i couldn't do that before i
didn't even know that i could do it
before i wasn't even sure that i could
complete it so yeah imposter syndrome is
a feature not a bug of growing as a
person i really like that that reframe
and um
it makes a lot of sense if you haven't
done something before where's the
[ __ ] proof that you're gonna be able
to do it
never lie
john peterson so whether it's by
omission or commission lying degrades
your virtue your internal sense of
self-worth is keeping check
even if you aren't telling the truth is
a superpower it works for everything
start being radically honest today and
your life will change so this is
one of the biggest changes i think i
made
between
my 20s and my 30s was how much i value
truth and how much i tried to focus on
telling the truth not because
i was lying all the time but just that
it's easier
sometimes it's easier
to feed people
a convenient
omission
or to tell people what you think that
they want to hear
or to give a more
i don't know
a more
acceptable
form of an answer or whatever it is
whatever it is that you're talking about
right
that was me for a very long time and the
problem with that
is that you can end up
telling little fibs and and curbing off
edges of yourself for so long that you
genuinely don't know who you are anymore
and you have to scrape all of that away
if you want to try and find out your
genuine opinion your truth your actual
inner most logos that you need to speak
forward if you want to try and do that
you have to scrape away all of the stuff
that you've piled on top of it all of
this muck and all of these layers and
layers and layers of you being
performative and saying what you think
people want to hear
it's not very nice like that was that
was the
largest amount of self-work that i still
have to get through now the biggest
chunk of it was me working out who i
genuinely
am
i mean that's hard enough on its own we
are a mystery to ourselves it's a
mystery to everybody especially
ourselves
and
yeah if you're if you're lying you're
not making that any easier
it's like
you're already struggling to see the
person that you are you're already
mostly a mystery
and now you're wearing a bunch of
different outfits and trying on
different opinions
that you know aren't yours so you're
just further muddying the waters that
you're trying to see through
so yeah i mean
almost all of the people that i know
that i really really value in life are
the ones that are incredibly truthful
and that doesn't mean that they'll um
not pull their punches that doesn't mean
that they won't say things in a
a charming or an empathetic or a caring
way i'm not saying that you need to be
in a brutal [ __ ] with everybody
but
that
with a little bit of
charm and
charisma
and care
you can deliver exactly what you
yourself need to hear what the people
around you need to hear whether it be at
work whether it's in a relationship
whether it's with your family whether
it's with friends
you can be a really really good
influence on them because
most people are just going to take the
easy route out of whatever the
conversation is if there's something
that if someone in your friend group
everybody knows that they need to stop
drinking but no one really wants to
bring it up with them
that
the fact that everybody knows it and
nobody's saying it is exactly why you
need to be the person that takes them to
one side and says hey man
i wanna should we what do we have a chat
about about how much you're drinking
like are you okay
is there anything that i can do to help
i i'm really concerned about you like
these are
more compassionate
sentences then i'll leave him he'll be
fine
no it doesn't really matter you know
john john's john's sweet john sweet he
just he likes to party he likes the sesh
nah
nah you can be the person that says the
thing that that person needs to hear
and if you
are only friends if the people around
you are only accepting of you when
you're lying
you need better friends
shane parish the wise of every
generation discover the same truths
the whys of every generation discover
the same truths this was really cool
because
there's this sort of yearning for
tradition that we have at the moment tim
stanley a couple of weeks ago he spoke
about that
and
it really does feel like
so many of the solutions that we come up
on are things that
you know your parents would have told
you it's like that midwife meme like the
the idiot and the genius uh arrive at
the same place and the midwife in the
middle is the one that doesn't it's like
the uh parent and you at
your highest virtue your highest wisdom
you arrive at the same thing and then
you in the middle is the one that's
trying to overcomplicate everything
the um
tradition is a set of solutions for
which we have forgotten the problems
take the solution away and often the
problem comes back so so many times
people are trying to reinvent the wheel
okay with relationships okay we see
rising divorce rates so uh maybe
um monogamous relationships uh horseshit
and we should all just try polyamory and
just [ __ ] everyone
um
yeah i mean that's one
that's one solution
or it could be that marriage is just a
bit hard and we've now got technology
that is throwing us to the
lions with regards to novelty and
distractibility
um and
i mean marriage rates are decreasing as
well the wise of every generation
discover the same truths there's been a
lot of
unlimited numbers of people that have
thought about the biggest questions that
plague all of us
why do you think
that in 2021 we're going to be able to
immediately just come up with a brand
new set of solutions for stuff these
have been split tested a lot an awful
lot
thousands and thousands
and thousands of people have been
consumed by the same thoughts that you
are every single day
whatever it is that's concerning you
whatever it is that you're worried about
that
belief
that you have a particularly unique
problem that no one on the planet has
ever faced before
is almost certainly horseshit
and
looking for solutions in the future of
the present
is probably a pretty bad idea
there's definitely someone that's come
up with that's faced what it is that
you're struggling with
the whys of every generation discovering
the same truths reminds us that
if you look back if you try and find a
little bit of wisdom from the past
there's probably an answer already there
the bleeding edge of internet culture
can predict downfalls six to 12 months
before most normies even realize that's
from
ryan long um so ryan's an interesting
guy he's this comedian dude i had on the
show
earlier this year
and he's like quite a bro kind of like
he's like 2021's version of american pie
sort of comedian used to be in this
really famous scar band uh in canada
like scar punk band and he's still got
that sort of punk rock thing going on
with the hair and the nose ring and he's
like just super browy about everything
um
but i find he's cool he's genuinely a
cool guy in a way that i don't think i
could ever be
and
his insight around
the absolute bleeding edge of culture
like he has his finger on the pulse
some of the things that he says in the
episode if you go back and listen to it
he drops some names and he makes some
just
what he takes for granted as part of
culture to me seems like something that
i've only glimpsed the very very corner
of so he'll bring up the name of someone
or he'll mention something about a
person that he doesn't think is very
cool or just a a passive put down about
some some content creator whatever it
might be
he does that
so seamlessly because to him it's
plainly obvious but this person or
whoever it is that he's talking about
does it on loads of his other videos as
well these people are still riding high
so dan bilzerian was a an example
if you looked at people like filion
who's an awesome youtuber that you
should check out
i think maybe coffeezilla did some stuff
on it i think tom
mc
[ __ ]
swedish looking guy with a beard who
does finance stuff tom somebody
um
those guys had done takedowns of dan
bilzerian they'd realized
probably a year ago
18 months ago or something like that
that dan bilzerian was kind of coming
across like a bit of a man child that he
was this
he was just weird there was something
just a little bit off he hadn't
positioned himself appropriately and
then look at what happened six to 12
months later it turns out that he's sort
of a bit of a charlatan who said that he
owned this huge house and he didn't he
was renting it and his company's
finances were in the toilet and it
seemed like he was getting bailed out by
his dad who had all of this money that
he got in this dodgy way and blah blah
blah blah
but if you had kept your ear to the
ground
on the right areas of the internet you'd
have been able to predict this 12 or 18
months in advance and that's
the
uh
world that people like ryan
kind of seem to be in now that's not me
saying that he's going to be
[ __ ] cassandra right and that he's
going to be able to predict absolutely
everything that happens for the rest of
time i don't think that that's right
but
the bleeding edge of internet culture
is
a pretty good window into the future you
know here's a perfect example wall
street bets i told the boys about wall
street but it was me me i broke i broke
the wall street uh story um
me and yousef and johnny
were watching the dankest trades
compilations on wall street bets
over a year ago before last summer we
were watching them and that was when the
i think the sub had
half a million people on it something
like that less than a million people
that were members of their reddit uh and
this is before gamestop this is before
the short squeeze this is before amc
this is before deep [ __ ] value
um
like before all of that before it became
a national news story and i don't know
how many people let me see how many
people are in wall street bets now wall
street
all three birds
how many people are in this subreddit
now
million 11.1 [ __ ] million people in
this so
we'd seen this a long long long time ago
and um
i thought this is [ __ ] cool like it
was being videos were being made by
people like kamikaze cash who are
they they know what they're talking
about they're really they spend a lot of
time on the internet they understand
internet culture they understand meme
culture and they know the sort of things
that are going to go viral like
culturally viral virality
and sure enough you roll the clock
forward and the
correct
sequence of circumstances occurs and it
the
channel what 10x is it's part it's on
news i mean that deep [ __ ] value guy
didn't give
i swear he gave
a talk to congress or something or some
some committee meeting or something in
america um
yeah
leading edge of the internet culture can
predict downfalls six to 12 months
before most normies even realize it
your framing is everything so this is dr
benjamin hardy and his new book uh the
gap and the gain kind of talks about
this so a good example that i use for
framing is
feeling like you just finished a workout
in the gym is amazing so
you go in this is what people actually
go for right they go into the gym to
make their lungs bleed to work hard to
do spinning class or yoga or
weightlifting or crossfit or whatever it
is they go in because the end of the
workout feels so good when they're lying
on the floor in a pool of sweat or when
they're walking out and they get to high
five their friends like those endorphins
that is precisely why they go there so
feeling like you just finished a workout
in the gym is amazing
but if you had the exact same experience
of finishing a workout while you were
sat spontaneously in traffic you'd be
terrified
oh hang on it's the exact same sensation
so
why does one make you feel great when
you're in the gym and the other one make
you feel terrified that you're having
some sort of aneurysm or heart attack
but it's because of framing it's because
the reason that you are prepared to put
up with the sweating and the heat and
the discomfort and all that stuff when
you're in the gym is you know it's in
service of something good because you've
just done a bunch of stuff that's led
you up to believe that that's good
whereas when you're sat in the car you
think what's going on am i dying
is this what it feels like to be adopted
by aliens like what you don't understand
what's happening because your framing
has changed so if you learn to control
how you frame situations you can
actually
alter your perspective you can not only
alter your perspective but you can also
alter what that situation even means to
you so
in the gap in the game which is ben
hardy's new book which you should get
quite short 260 pages
you
are always going to have a problem
with framing if you compare yourself
against how you could or should have
performed
comparing yourself against what you
could or should have done is like trying
to race toward the horizon no matter how
hard you work you're always going to
come up short so that's another case of
framing okay you can look at
you do a thing
when you do the thing
you can compare yourself with how far
away from your potential you are or how
far from your starting point you are
okay
one is the gap
versus potential one is the gain from
starting point
now
if you compare yourself against where
you could have been you are never ever
going to get there
maybe you're going to glimpse it a
couple of times in your life but even
professional athletes don't perform at
the 100
of their perfect potential like they
make mistakes as well we see it every
single day and that's the professional
athletes that's their job they're
employed to be as perfect as po as
possible at one very specific narrow
domain
so what hope have you got of giving a
talk at work or going on a date or
having a conversation with a partner or
whatever it might have been whatever
pursuit it is that you're going after if
you frame the situation as
you idiot look at how much better you
could have been or should have been well
yeah obviously obviously that's going to
be the case because i'm never going to
hit 100
but how far have i come look at how
different this particular performance
was versus the last one and even if it's
gone backwards you can say okay well
that's another rep in the tank that's
another ship of a product i've shipped
it again that's another iteration that i
can learn from it's another opportunity
for me to get better
the difference in terms of framing gap
and gain
is really really powerful and i'm glad
that
ben has now given a name to it the gap
in the game is a an awesome one i don't
know whether
the episode might not be out yet or it
might have just come out but if it's not
out it'll be out soon uh this is the
weird and wonderful world of uh
scheduling podcasts in advance
don't practice what you do not want to
become
so
this is a jordan peterson quote
that made me think about an episode i
did with james clear the james clear
episode was
two years ago
maybe even more
i did it
i did it in america
in redlands which is just inland from
uh la
and i propped my laptop up on
two
tables
in the hotel room where i was staying
and i'd tried to light myself with a
desk lamp that kept on
turning off during the episode so um
yeah don't practice what you do not want
to become which is a guy that balances
his laptop on two tables um every action
you take is a vote for the kind of
person you're going to be in the future
if you do a thing today
it's more likely that you'll do it
tomorrow
this includes negative self-talk and a
lack of compassion for yourself
treat your habits with requisite care
so
don't practice what you do not want to
become reminds us that
every single time you do a thing you
make doing that thing more likely again
in future if you do or don't break your
diet then tomorrow it's going to be more
likely that you do or don't break your
diet if you do or don't go to the gym if
you do or don't have a difficult
conversation with your partner
every single if you do or don't pick up
your phone when you don't need to or um
break that promise that you made to
yourself by not using social media
before a particular time or pressing the
snooze button all of these things are
contributing to a future
where you are going to be the sort of
person that is more likely to do the
thing that you've just done
that's how habits work
there's a story about a woman a girl who
was horse riding when she was a kid and
her parents were quite strict and she
didn't want to get caught smoking when
she turned into a teenager but her
parents didn't follow her to horse horse
riding so her and her friends would go
out horse riding and they'd smoke while
they were on the horses and then she'd
come back and she'd muck to the horses
out or whatever so she'd mask the smell
uh and then she stops she
gets pregnant when she's a bit young
and has a kid and then 10 or 12 years
later decides oh well i'm going to take
my child's horse riding because it was
something beautiful and it's something
that my mom introduced me to and this
will be really good 10 or 12 years she
hasn't had a cigarette sits on a horse
wants to have a cigarette again
instantly she's stopped for 12 years but
sitting on the horse was the trigger
that she wanted a cigarette and that
craving still existed
why
well
it's because the way that myelin sheaths
lay down the way that our brains work is
that it's really quite hard to atrophy
connections in the brain once they're
made
if you have your phone
always on one side of your desk as soon
as you put your phone back there even if
you didn't have it for 10 years you're
going to be able to pick it up because
those wirings still exist in your brain
so
one thing that you can do mentioned
phone use a lot here to try and pattern
interrupt the
way that your brain sees this is to
just switch some things around so an
easy one is to if you're a guy and you
where you put your phone in pockets put
your phone in the other pocket and put
your wallet let's say that you've got
phone in right pocket and wallet in left
if you swap it around it's going to pat
and interrupt that natural thing that
you've got in your mind where you just
put your hand in your pocket and you
pull your phone out that's going to
change almost instantly so
that's one way to fix it to try and
change little roots and routines and
pattern interrupt what your brain is
expecting to happen rearranging the
menu on your phone moving
different icons around in different
places is another really good one
because
more than anything when you get your
phone out you know your brain
understands
where particular triggers are on the
phone it's not as if you're pressing the
icons it's as if there's a cue craving
and reward that's already embedded into
your thumb
via your brain
and your thumb is just following that
little routine but if you break the
routine and now
[ __ ] barclays banking app is where
facebook used to be and you press on
that
it's going to stop you so adding in
these extra layers of friction and
pattern interrupting that is a really
good thing to do i actually considered
i mean this would be total sacrilege but
i'd actually considered getting an
android phone i could barely say it
getting an android phone
because i knew that i wouldn't be able
to
use
the same
uh modes uh phone use um i'm used to on
an iphone it's gonna be so it's gonna be
a complete departure right the operating
system
this would be an awesome thing for phone
manufacturers to do
to
offer
different types of operating system so
imagine if ios had
10 different ways that the interface
could look not just the way that the
icons are positioned but even the way
that you navigate around the phone and
what the gestures mean
and how you swipe perhaps
if you were able to totally patent break
what it was you're doing yeah you have
the same device in your hand but the way
that you use it has to be completely
different
that would be so good because it would
basically be like starting again but
yeah i mean it
it scares me it honestly does scare me
some of the bad habits that we pick up
they're with us for the rest of our
lives now we can replace them with other
good habits but getting rid
of habits that you've already created
is really really difficult i mean i
asked anna lemke this that dopamine
researcher only the other week and said
you know can you kind of get rid of
addictions and
she gave she kind of gave a bit of a
diploma diplomatic answer um
it seems like you can definitely
overcome addictions
but there's always kind of going to be
something there
so yeah don't practice what you do not
want to become
is a simple sense but it's oddly
existential
another thing as well is i'm really glad
that phones weren't around even sooner
because embedding these particular
habits when you're younger
is significantly easier think about how
easy it was to learn stuff when you're
in school right like or languages
there's some
stats i saw about how much harder it is
to learn a language i think after the
age of 13 something like that so your
brain is just primed for taking in
information and learning habits right
when you're younger
but most kids have got ipads or phones
and i am so glad if i think about how
challenging i find technology use now uh
compared with
how long i've been using it and then
think okay now double the amount of time
that you've been using an iphone
from
i think i probably got one when i was
about 25
yeah it'd be more than double that's
terrifying that's scary
uh
corey allen you are not your thoughts so
corey is a meditation teacher and a
producer music producer and he makes
binaural beats he makes some [ __ ] hot
binaural beats for meditation and for
deep focus and stuff you should check
those out if you're looking for some new
ones
the voice that speaks in your head is
not you you are the one who hears it
speak
don't identify with what your mind says
any more than you identify with what
someone on the street says this is one
of the most liberating truths to know so
with this it's reminding us that
you don't know what you're going to
think next
you don't know what you're going to
think next if you don't know what you're
going to think next how can you say that
the voice in your head is you it's just
another element think about the fact
when you've lost your keys and you say
to yourself
uh where are my keys
who the [ __ ] are you talking to
genuinely
who the actual [ __ ] are you talking to
i've lost my keys where are my keys
there's only you inside of your head is
there not well no if there's someone
speaking then there has to be a listener
and the person that's speaking is just
this
weird amalgamation
of sleep deprivation and hunger and
excess caffeine and limbic hijack and
thought loops
and what you've just seen on twitter and
that repetitive song that's on the radio
that you can't get rid of
you are not your thoughts
so when you
hear something you hear a particular
piece of monologue that's in your head
that you're saying
you wouldn't identify if someone on the
street just accused you of being that
thing
so genuinely ask yourself why do you
choose to identify with what your head
says
do you have faith in your own word
maybe okay well
how many times have you thought a thing
that didn't turn out to be true
you are your most untrustworthy friend
the voice that's inside of your head
is batting
it's got the worst average in history
imagine all of the things that you've
thought
that didn't turn out to be true all of
the concerns that you had all the
worries
all of the fears and the overthinking
and the absolute certainties about
whatever catastrophe was going to occur
or absolute certainties about whatever
success was going to occur and it didn't
if you were friends with that person
you would think that they were the
biggest gobshite
on planet you'd be like
what dude all that you do is spew
misinformation at me on a daily basis
what are you talking about
but because the voice comes from inside
of us we trust it
you are not your thoughts it was really
good from corey should go back and
listen to an episode i did with him on
binaural beats uh back end of last year
because he splices the binaural beats in
between the episodes so we're talking
about different delta waves and theta
waves and beta waves and stuff
and um he cuts them in it's beautiful
it's really cool for him to do that
um
action is the antidote to anza anxiety
action is the antidote to anxiety this
was rich divani who was a navy seal and
he founded the seal mind gym
which was the
sort of mental
optimization
wing
of the navy seals up until then i don't
think that the seals had really focused
on
optimizing or maximizing mental
performance they'd obviously spent a lot
of time doing physical stuff
but they hadn't really optimized it
mentally so action is the antidote to
anxiety you're not afraid of the future
when you're moving yourself toward it do
something anything you'll feel better
this is
a realization that i've had as well when
i feel bad when i'm
if finding myself with a low mood
it's often
i can manage to assuage that feeling by
just doing something that moves me
towards my goals that moves me a bit
closer toward the life that i want to
have
towards the project that i genuinely
care about
you're not afraid of the future when
you're moving yourself toward it it's
the helplessness that comes with
uh stagnation
you have
this
sense this nagging sense in the back of
your head that you should be doing a
thing
that you could be
spending this time when you feel a
little bit anxious or you feel a little
bit down and
you're a little bit guilty
because
look at all of this time that i'm
wasting just reveling in my own pity
and then if you can do anything if you
can take a tiny tiny little step let's
say that
you're feeling a bit a bit bad today and
you know that going for a walk would
make you feel better taking the dog out
going to the gym doing whatever
the tiniest tiniest little step that you
can take toward doing that even
going to the gym to do a push-up
would be
such a huge accomplishment because it is
infinitely more than you were about to
do and once you're there you know that
you're going to do more so action is the
antidote to anxiety is a
it's a really good thing to remember
most of the anxiety that we suffer with
comes about because we're not
we're not in control or we don't feel
like we're in control of the future
right we're concerned about what's
coming next because we're not
controlling the speed and the direction
that we move toward it so try and take a
little bit of control
what do we got next
uh
joy has to be found today not tomorrow
so this is
uh
johnny wilkinson went on the high
performance podcast um and damian hughes
and
the other guy whose name escapes me
sorry
um
[ __ ] man johnny wilkinson sounds like
johnny wilkinson sounds like a woke
aubry marcus he sounds like someone
that's done 100 ayahuasca sessions i'd
love to find out if he's done any
psychedelics because he's very he's all
about spiritual
enlightenment and being awakened and in
the present you think this guy
this guy tackled people to grass
for a living he kicked he kicked an
egg-shaped ball and tackled people to
the ground
uh i didn't expect to see it from johnny
wilkinson but it was it was really
really good he's talking about this
story where he's with his daughter
they're playing basketball at a fun fair
and he's treating it like some
mindfulness exercise there is no fun
fair there is no world there is no
tomorrow there is no con
sweets to get after this there is simply
the next shot and he's talking about
this degree of presence that he has when
he's playing basketball with his
daughter
uh but naval via eric jorgensen who came
on the show
uh sort of really
drives this home with
if you can't be happy with the coffee
you won't be happy with a yacht
choose to find joy in today it's there
waiting for you
this is just the classic looking past
today in the hopes of being happy
tomorrow thing you're not going to be
become happy you can only be happy there
is no becoming happy there is just being
happy
what do you mean if you're not going to
be happy right now with the things that
are going on what makes you think that
tomorrow is going to be the case and
remember if we don't want to practice
what we don't want to become you're
already putting yourself in a habit
of putting off happiness until tomorrow
so what happens when tomorrow comes well
you're already in the habit of putting
off happiness until tomorrow so when
it's tomorrow then why not put it off
until tomorrow and when it's tomorrow
why not and so on and so on
joy has to be found today not tomorrow
if you can't be happy with a coffee you
won't be happy with a yacht choose to
find joy in today it's there waiting for
you everything that you do whether it's
cleaning the dishes or speaking to a
friend the way that you frame it your
framing is everything
the way that you frame it as yeah i've
got to do this job or this task that i'm
not too sure about so a good example
right tomorrow um
i'm helping darren business partner who
is launching a bar everyone should go to
2020 in newcastle it's on the big market
opposite at the point it's going to be
awesome they've got
pizza that's double the size of dominoes
and they do craft coffee and all sorts
of stuff 20 20.
i'll put the link there'll be a website
somewhere that'll come up um
tomorrow he needs to put some of the
upholstery [ __ ] in there whatever sofas
and
chairs and heavy stuff so we're gonna
spend most of tomorrow
lifting heavy things around like it's
not going to be particularly fun
but i can find a bit of joy in doing
that tomorrow and i'm going to have to
remind myself while my legs are raking
and i'm sweating and i'm shouting at him
because he's not turning it the right
way
but that's an opportunity for me to
spend a day with my best mate and
business partner helping him create a
project that he really really cares
about but if i spent that day thinking
oh i can't wait for it to be over so i
can go and see the fireworks at night
time because we've got this fireworks
show on
that well i've just wasted all of these
opportunities every single one of these
opportunities to be joyful don't get me
wrong right i'm
absolutely saying this to myself this is
i'm
the perfect exemplar of someone that
does look past the now just
slightly peers over the shoulder of now
even when we think that we are being
present we just look past it a slight
way
but yeah
if you can't be happy with the coffee
then you won't be happy with the yacht
if you can enjoy the little things that
you've got whether it be
trying to
be as present and awakened as possible
whilst playing basketball with your
daughter or
whatever else it is lifting furniture
with your business partner i think
that's a good place to start keep
promises to yourself
your faith in your own word is vital if
you can't trust yourself you're making a
chaotic world even more difficult to
navigate build up your self-trust with
small promises over time will be able to
take on bigger challenges
this again was a big reflection for me
from the self work that i did between my
20s and my 30s that because i had played
a persona a lot and i'd sort of been
this
version of me that had maybe degraded my
trust in myself
my belief in my own honesty
that i didn't
believe that i was going to do the
things that i said i was going to do i
mean first off
uh i was believing that the voice of my
head was me so i'd already already
[ __ ] up once but i didn't have faith
that the promises i made to myself were
going to be completed so imagine that
you have a friend that you invite out
for lunch a lot and every time you
invite this friend out they always turn
up late every single [ __ ] time always
turning up late or
sometimes don't show up at all
total just most unreliable friend in the
world
over time you're going to stop inviting
that friend out for dinner because you
do not believe that they're actually
going to show up
well you are that friend to yourself
you have a counter in the back of your
mind even if you don't think
that you're keeping track of all of the
times that you've broken a promise to
yourself there is a part of you that
does
it degrades your value
every time that you decide to break a
promise to yourself it degrades your own
inner sense of virtue if you're the sort
of person if you're like me
and i think that in this regard a lot of
people that listen to modern wisdom are
you genuinely care about trying to be a
good person you genuinely have a
conscience and you want to feel virtuous
and and
you know like your
actions match up with your intentions
and that you're leaving the world in a
better place than you found it
this means that you need to be able to
have faith in yourself if you do not
trust that you are going to do the
things that you say that you're going to
do
what is their fee what what firm place
have you got to stand upon
like how are you going to be able to
predict the future you are the person
over whom you have the most control in
the world you only have marginal control
over yourself but you're the person you
have the most control over and if you
can't trust
that you will do the things that you
said that you were going to do to
yourself by your own volition under your
own control
what [ __ ] hope is that what hope is
there for you to be able to make a
relationship with another person work
when you can't trust yourself to do the
things that you said that you were going
to do should i do one more i'll do one
more i'll treat you to one more i was
going to try and get some brian rose
quotes from london real but
you blocked me so
i'll do that
okay
most problems are easily fixed 90 of
issues can be solved by good sleep a
glass of water a gym session a walk
outdoors or a chat with a friend so this
was johan hari that kind of got me onto
this and his book lost connections about
depression is a really good read and
it reminds us that most of the recent
history for depression was seen as a
depression was classified as an
imbalance of chemicals in the brain
whereas johan changes that around and
says part of it is imbalances in the
brain but other parts of it are unmet
needs by your life so if you're not
getting up regularly having a good diet
getting exercise having sunlight you
don't have a job that you feel like you
contribute to you don't have a purpose
in life you don't have friends and
connections if you don't have these
things like what [ __ ] hope have you
got of being happy these are the
fundamental things that you require as a
human being just to exist in a
moderately optimal way forget [ __ ]
optimal this is like basic requirements
if you're not doing these things of
course you're how how could you be happy
to be happy
whilst not getting that stuff sorted
you you would have to be some sort one
of those people that's been hit in the
head with a rock and now they're
their brains just dumping serotonin into
them relentlessly just unloading
serotonin just in this blissed-out state
most problems can be easily fixed by
doing something that changes your
current state so for me going for a walk
or going to the gym
they that is
the difference that i feel after i go
and do those things
is otherworldly and
most problems that you have
aren't that big like yes
you have big problems and big problems
probably
i'm not sure if a glass of water is
going to fix your big problems but 90 of
your problems are more than that 99 of
your problems aren't big problems
they're just
an awkward conversation that you had
with that person at work that's really
really riled you up
okay well
why not try going to the gym why not try
and work out some aggression that way
why not get a good night's sleep are you
under slept has this pissed you off
because you're really badly slept or
because you've got tons of nervous
energy you haven't trained for ages or
because you're under hydrated or because
you haven't seen sunlight because the
middle of winter you haven't you haven't
been outside and got any fresh air today
or because you haven't spoken to a
friend and you've been neurotic you've
been constantly replaying whatever
situation it is i can't believe that
[ __ ] said that to me
90 of problems can be solved by a good
sleep glass of water a gym session walk
outdoors or a chat with a friend
so when you feel bad when there's
something that's playing on your mind
that's annoying you just pulling that
pin the same way
as the mindfulness gap from meditation
it causes you to try and just take a
little breath in between stimulus and
response right something happens and you
you just take a little breath in between
because you think i don't need to
respond immediately i have the
opportunity to choose how i want to
respond the same thing can occur with
this let's say that there's a problem
that you have you have the opportunity
without before you descend into neurotic
rumination
you can go all right
let's see if i can do something to make
this feel a little bit better let's see
if i can
go for a walk or before i actually try
and respond to this let's see if i can
get a good night's sleep and
that's why i like johan's book
i know that you got criticized i heard
that he got criticized uh in the
guardian
for
i'm going to guess that they would have
said he was like downplaying
depression
de-medicalizing it perhaps underplaying
the way that
uh hormonal or
neurochemical imbalance in the brain
stuff
but what i liked about his book
was that it puts the
power back in the hands of the person
that's suffering with the low mood
the best takeaway from
uh
johan's book was that
it means that you are the person that's
in control
lost connections
repurposes
the um
domain of control from being outside of
you to being inside of you there is
something that you can do
about the way that you feel that's so
much more [ __ ] empowering than oh
good luck with that imbalance of
hormones in the brain mate hope you get
hit with a rock at the right angle well
there you go there's some ssris crack on
without erections for the rest of your
life like [ __ ] that so
yeah giving yourself the best
opportunity to be happy by doing the
things in your life that create the
fundamental foundation for happiness
is a good way to begin and the same
things happen there's a catastrophe that
occurs something goes wrong
okay well can i do something that's
going to make me feel better i know that
these things maybe for you it's
different maybe you
hate walking and you want to do
stretching or yoga or something but
most of those are good places to start
if you do all of them
i
pretty certain that almost all almost
all problems except for the big ones are
going to get fixed
look thank you that is
some lessons i don't know how many i did
that is some lessons from 400
episodes of the podcast and nearly four
years
uh i will be in austin by the time you
watch this
which is also going to be exciting i'm
going to be recording while i'm out
there and
yeah i mean i started doing three
episodes a week at the beginning of the
pandemic because
i kind of made a promise to you guys
that i i wanted to
um give you more of a sense of
community and connection and more stuff
to distract you from what was being a
fairly shitty year
and don't practice what you do not want
to become i've ended up uh embedding the
habit that if i do any less than three
weeks now um i
it doesn't feel right there's something
wrong so
um
the show is going to continue at this
unrelenting pace
for quite a while longer um i really
really appreciate everybody that listens
and tunes in and shares the episodes and
does whatever and joins the locals the
locals community we've got uh
that'll be up here it might be on the
end card if you want to join and speak
to other people that are just like you
and talk about the episodes and connect
with me and connect with the rest of the
audience you can go and join there right
now that'll end up
here maybe um
yeah
thank you
roll on episode 500.
[Music]
you